wenn ich an all das denke was ich in
meinem
aber ohne jemals da
werden
baustert jack bild ist ein song von
metallica aber eigentlich ein film von
lars von trier
sie enden oder film von lars von trier
deren serien filme ist und sowohl er wie
seine hauptfigur gehen einem ziemlich an
die nieren und das soll es auch
[Musik]
metal ist der serienmörder der ehemalige
teenie-schwarm und bruno ganz ist der
alte wohlwollende aber irgendwie auch
übermüdet und verzweifelte geister hin
in die hölle führt wo er hingehört das
war vielleicht ein fehler war dass ich
bei ihnen eingestiegen bin
sie könnten ja ein serienmörder sein
entschuldigung aber sie sehen ein wenig
danach aus
er gehört die hölle weil er ganz viele
leute umgebracht hat und zwar auf
möglichst sadistische weise da er sonst
nichts empfindet und dabei eigentlich
auch nichts empfindet was er dabei
empfindet ist das was sein design ist
und dass das kunst sei hier die leute
zerlegt und ängstigt usw
also erhält sich sozusagen für den autor
der designer von irgendwelchen
interessanten situationen und bruno ganz
in dem film ist dazu da die frage zu
stellen willst du nicht einfach nur ein
schwein das ist aber die frage die lars
von trier auch an sich selbst stellt in
der witz ist es geht nicht nur darum
dass jemand seine grausamkeiten mit
kunst verwechselt sondern auch darum
dass es kunst gibt die eventuell eben
auch sich nur mit kunst verwechselt und
wirklichkeit auch eine grausame oder
psychopathologische relevant ist einige
behaupten die gräueltaten die wir in der
literatur verüben seien jene inneren
sehnsüchte die wir in unserer
kontrollierten zivilisation nicht
ausleben können
stattdessen drücken wir sie durch unsere
kunst aus ich sehe das nicht so
ich glaube himmel und hölle sind ein und
dasselbe die seele gehört im himmel und
er lag der l
[Musik]
also den vorwurf dass er sich nicht
überlegt hat zum beispiel den kann man
nicht machen obwohl es kann sehr
analytischer sondern ein sehr
chaotischer filmemacher ist aber in
diesem fall ist es tatsächlich so wie
bei stephen king in bestimmten büchern
in den neunzigern wo die frage plötzlich
im raum steht das grausame zeug was ich
mache angesichts der tatsächlichen
grausamkeiten die es auf der welt gibt
ist es nicht eigentlich immer
verharmlosung oder verherrlichung weil
am jahr werde man so was dreht oder wenn
man sowas anguckt eigentlich nichts
passiert und man damit möglicherweise
abstumpft dadurch das ist eine ziemlich
ernste frage denn andererseits gar keine
kunst über diese dinge zu machen und gar
nicht über diese dinge zu reden außer im
kontext und wo sie dann wirklich
körperlich weh tun ist natürlich auch
kein weg für menschen denn wir müssen
uns ja irgendwie ein bildnis machen von
dem was wir tun wenn das unterbrechen
wollen oder ändern wollen oder anders
erscheinen solltest du das jetzt zu
sagen ich habe immer mit finger auf
andere gezeigt jetzt sage ich mal mit
finger auf mich mal gucken ob es piept
und das pik ganz schön ich kann es
allerdings nicht als familienfilm oder
überhaupt als film für leute die nicht
gerne gesehen im 4
[Musik]
die frauen sind ein großes thema in der
öffentlichen reaktion darauf gewesen
viele leute sind in cannes bei der
vorführung rausgelaufen was ich gut
verstehen kann denn es gibt halt
irgendwie so eine schwelle für jede und
jeden wo man sagt jetzt wird es mir
irgendwie zu nahe an dingen die es
wirklich gibt und die abscheulich sind
ich glaube aber nicht dass man sagen
kann das ist ein frauenfeindlicher film
ist dazu ist es viel zu
menschenfeindlicher film beziehungsweise
dazu geht es wie so sehr darum wie in
roman bestimmte menschen eben sind zu
anderen menschen dh der sadismus zu den
frauen ist relativ lange im mittelpunkt
bis dann das ding bericht an der stelle
wo bruno ganz selber sagt also der der
den mördern gefragt wieso redest du
immer von diesen frauen und wie du die
sind möchte ist da und damit eventuell
wieder so eine rechtfertigung sting
fahren im sinne von die sind nur
material für ein genie als mörder und
das heißt insoweit dass ein problem ist
handelt der film von dem problem er hat
es nicht einfach er handelt davon
hast du mein ich nehme wir sicherlich
irgendwelche tabletten empfehlen kann
ich den filmleuten die drastische kunst
mögen die aber wissen dass es dabei ein
problem gibt das heißt die crowd die
einfach nur gewaltpornos sehen will und
dabei irgendwie lachen oder mit popcorn
werfen der wird es nicht besser gehen
dann auch was vielleicht auch verdient
ist insofern sollten die eigentlich auch
eingehen ich weiß sie wollen jemand
besonderes ein check aber ganz ehrlich
dieses bild passt so leidensgeschichte
jedes suchtkranken der alkoholika lehrt
die flasche auch auf dem zenit täter
aber was ich mit familie